The first step in the process is to test the vaccine in a lab...
...on either human cells or on animals,...
...just to see if it causes any harm.
This is called the preclinical phase.
If it passes that test, it enters human trials.
This is the longest and most important part.
If it passes human trials, the vaccine gets licensed by regulators...
...and can be manufactured and distributed to the public.
Human trials typically have three phases,...
...each one testing a larger and larger group of people.
Phase 1 involves a very small group of people, maybe 50,...
...and mainly tests if the vaccine is safe.
Phase 2 usually involves a few hundred participants.
This is where we start learning if the vaccine actually works.
And there's the final test: the Phase 3 trial.
It's expensive, it takes time, it requires tens of thousands of volunteers,...
...and it involves as broad a cross-section of participants as possible,
The entire process of developing a vaccine usually takes around 10 years,...
...but many COVID-19 vaccine developers are racing to compress this entire process...
...into about a year and a half.
One way they're doing this is to overlap the different phases,...
...conducting several different trials at once,...
...or, to ramp up the manufacturing of a vaccine...
...while it's still being tested,...
...so that if it works, it can be distributed right away.